on n'a pas idée de reconversion
imaginons que vous deviez faire notre
métier je serai quoi je me la fait tous
les soirs c'est non moi je ne sais pas
du tout même à dire mannequin le mot
alors il est flatteur vous vont c'est la
pilote pardon il a de quoi d'alors
l'aviation un pilote d'avion
bah oui oui d'aviation sur l'avion
subrenat leucan hélicoptère de bio des
bonnes choses pour commencer à bosser
quand même delphine bout moi j'aurais
bien aimé faire boulangère pour vendre
des petits pains être les stocks
ben je peux les manger quand il en reste
voilà isabelle bravo pour la punir
imaginons que vous ne soyez pas dû
rester elle vous feriez vous elle compte
en flic fiq les mais avec moi vous aimez
dans l'émission commence à se rassembler
et de n'importe quoi de plus début quand
la fois la rangée folle et la rendre ces
jeux de leur mort
c'est compliqué parce qu'il ya plusieurs
choses que je sais faire dont j'aurai un
peu j'aurais pilote de formule un acteur
dont karting à acteur porno ou barbe
peut-être aussi se laissera peut être
animateur aussi
ne partez pas l'aventuré de très bonnes
bases similaires
nous avons mis tout le monde
il ya belle ça va je voulais aller
déjeuner concert de métal pour elle
était à fond m e thomas me gally berda
chante s à oui ça c'est pas une bonne
nouvelle pour nous oui mais bon pourquoi
pas non mais surtout pas surtout pas
belle finition a placé le poste
d'animatrice